pour sécuriser ses trajets quotidiens
hervé ne se contente plus d'un casque
cet ingénieur s'est doté d'un nouveau
compagnon de route
le harnais lumineux
porté sur vous c'est pas agi dessin on
est savoureux plus disait exactement
seulement beaucoup plus visible et en
particulier au niveau des intersections
au niveau des voitures qui du coup font
beaucoup plus attention à moi le
problème c'est que en discutant avec les
personnes c'est qu'il ne m'avait pas vu
et depuis j'avoue ça peut arriver mais
beaucoup moins
être bien vu au milieu des quatre-roues
de jour comme de nuit et devenue
indispensable le cycliste aujourd'hui
les noyer dans la circulation et l'idée
ça a été de le rendre visible à 360° de
jour comme de nuit de manière à prévenir
les accidents et à sauver des vies une
innovation technique unique en france
réalisée il ya deux ans par deux
universitaires d'orléans
la ressortie
l'ancien un plan de travail exactement
toute la panoplie déjà redémarré
l'impression 3d un harnais bourré de
technologie avec câble dissimulés dans
l'es11 télécommande et comodo hatay
réduit on le commando qui a été design
et et bien pour le coup il sorti
directement fait de l'impression 3d on a
imprimé plus de 400 avec l'impression 3d
une production onéreuse 50 euros l'unité
que nicolas s'empresse découler sur
internet saluée
mais aussi chez son buraliste regarde
les proto qu'on avait fait donc tu vois
ça c'était vraiment le premier sas et le
deuxième en fait voilà bonjour justement
je
vous quitte à jouer le vendeur ambulant
au milieu des revues quand vous détectez
une différence de vitesse et bien en
fait ça fait comme s'il défend il salue
mais voilà si vous chutez les warnings
il se met en marche automatiquement
parce que c'est le fait qu'il soit
illuminée enfin mais j'en ai jamais vu
des comme ça après les férus de vélo les
deux créateurs comptent séduire les
professionnels du bâtiment et des
travaux publics